LINES HEAD TO HEAD.
FORGET ABOUT A MATCHUP WORRY.
GET YOUR BEST P
MacKINNON STOPPED UP
CLEAR IT RIGHT HERE.
MAGIC.
>> Craig: HE TRIED TO SLIDE IT
ACROSS TO HYMAN AND PLAY THERE.
BYRAM ABLE TO GET HIS GLOVE ON
IT.
[ Horn ]
[ Cheering and Applause ]
OVER THE GLOVE.
NOW THE LEFTY NUGENT-HOPKINS.
THERE'S YOYO
ZACH HYMAN ON THE BACKDOOR,
MAYBE A SECONDS
HOW ABOUT MAKAR.
TWO ATTEMPTS TO GET THAT PUCK
OUT.
MAKAR KEEPS IT ALIVE. STOP ON A
TOUGH DEFLECTION BY ZACH SHOT!
SCORES!
A HALF SLAPPER ONE-TIMER JUST IN
A PERFECT PLACE AVALANCHE ARE B
OFF HIS CHEST.
THE
STARS START TO SHINE.
>> Craig: YOU KNE
SHOT.
IN FULL STRIDE.
OVER THE GLOVE OF MIKE SMITH IN
JUST
IT'S A POWER PLAY GO-AHEAD GOAL.
BLUE.
THAT ONE GOES 5-HOLE AND THROUGH
HIM.
INSTEAD HE STOPS ON THE NET.
THE PUCK IS RIGHT THERE.
HE G